made by ph/ Rayan Mahmoud
faculty of pharmacy , alexandria university
a stroke occurs when the blood flow
in part of your brain is blocked
after just few minutes
the starved brain cells begin to die
normally the brain recieves blood
via two major pairs of arteries
which branch to   brain tissue
and supply your brain cells with
a constant flow of oxygen , glucose and nutrients
necessary for their functions
in one type of stroke " ischemic stroke "
an artery in your brain narrows
or becomes completely blocked
preventing normal blood flow
the blockage may be caused by blood clot also called a thrombus
which forms in unhealthy artery of the brain
the lockup of blood flow causes the tissue
the artery supplies to be come starved or ischemic
similarly the blochage may be due to " embolus "
a blood clot that forms elsewhere in the body
and travels to the brain
the embolus lodges in a narrowered artery and abstructs blood flow
immediate treatment for stroke may help minimize
the brain cell injury and death
if you have an ischemic stroke
you may be given medication to break up
the clot causing your stroke
later your doctor may recommend surgery
such as carotid endarterectomy to reduce your risk
of having another ischemic stroke
made by ph/ Rayan Mahmoud
faculty of pharmacy , alexandria university